it was really good to be back and uh I
think one reason that I put on weight I
wasn't very happy because she's
what she was yeah she seemed like yeah
people mentioned this during our live
show we did everyone was like Chris
seems actually happy he likes life yeah
Chris is really energetic and happy
about being in the UK I mean yeah yeah
the first half of this year I was not
myself really I just I wasn't yeah happy
and uh yeah you know I think it's just
not going home seeing family for all
that time does that and Japan is great
but it can weigh you down and yeah
there's lots of things that can bug you
and you need to leave the country once
every year or twice a year preferable
yeah so and I didn't do that for three
years I haven't seen my family and I
think there was a lot of mounting
anxiety and pressure about that yeah and
that's why I ate all the cheese
the main reasons
did you notice anything different about
the UK this time that you went back
nothing works so nothing works
everyone's on strike constantly now the
day we went to this luxurious restaurant
with Barry Chopstick like we the [ __ ]
trains went there because yeah Jerry and
I had to like battle our way through
London
I was really angry and Conor was like
what was the name under I was like oh
you think he's under Chopsticks I want
so and every time I went to London there
was a there was a strike of some sort
yeah yeah I'm all four strikes just not
when I'm there
Chris is coming into town which is
probably wait a minute I went to London
maybe three times and yeah I I was very
unlucky every time was the time I was
going in I I've had such bad experiences
with cab drivers uh with like Uber
drivers and stuff in London that I
actually got a black cab one time oh
that's a London official Yeah official
London Camp I was like uh can you take
me here and now I was like you say yeah
I was like do you know like where that
is and he looked at me he's like
so you know I'm a London cab driver
right of course I know where that is and
then I was like all right okay all right
obviously he knew yeah I was just like
all right sorry mate I was just making
sure because I thought it may be a
little specific I don't know that's how
you know you're too used to Japanese
characters it's Japanese because they
never know where you're going well
that's that's why I like London like
there was like this big strike with like
London black cab drivers when Uber first
got launched because you have to go
through like a rigorous set of
qualifications to get like your black
cab license right know the streets no
London in and out and then off up comes
Uber and the [ __ ] technology with GPS
and suddenly that knowledge is useless
now well not useless but it's completely
unfair to the the black cab drivers yeah
it sucks though because it's like you
know when I when I lived in London it
was just Uber but now there's like four
uh like giant like uh one of the cab
ride share what are the [ __ ]
Rideshare companies
and they all drove all the prices down
yeah of like because Uber used to be
really expensive about a chance of
getting a normal cap but that bolts and
stuff and all the other companies it's
ridiculously cheap to get a cab now in
London with one of these apps so you
know it's hard to get people to be like
yeah we should we should keep the cabs
but also I really don't want to pay 50
pound for a 20 minute Journey I'd rather
pay 20 pounds yeah it's kind of it's
hard to you know get people on board
with it when they're like I I like like
cheaper cabs but I feel like part of it
is due to the fact that London is such
like a heavily tourist country
yeah black cabs are just I guess like
part of that experience I mean that's
the only I can't think of any other
reasons they would choose to keep the
[ __ ] red phone boxes because they all
smell of piss like you go to London no
no [ __ ] London I go for ghosts take a
Pedro I realize one of my friends want
to take a picture of the red uh the
boxes like all of them looked really bad
and they were like is there going to be
one that doesn't look bad like
five percent chance yeah that's good
we're only in a closed off area like
maybe
yeah because I remember first time
Sydney went to the UK when she moved
here she was like so excited to see one
of the red like phone books she was like
oh my God it's one of the red phone
boxes oh my god get your phone out we're
gonna take a picture right now she
[ __ ] bolts in opens the door rushes
in picks up the phone box oh and then as
soon as she does she just gets hit with
this wave of smell and she's just like
that's just a picture of just Cindy with
the phone watch you go
that's like her first experience
in the UK
yeah but some other days it was really
really busy and I was just like oh this
is [ __ ] did this IRL stream on Connor's
Channel obviously yeah down with Tim so
we stopped this restaurant this guy came
over with this really nice like toy doll
what was it it was a John no Giovanna
pen and he tried to give it to you at
the like the trash taste London event
right right yeah and he's like I can
make it and what a coincidence I've just
run into you here definitely not stream
sniping him anyway he gave kind of this
toy yeah you're trying
thank you very much and the guys
and then we're still in the Stream and
Colin just went uh just broke it there
and there
on the floor not on purpose and then the
chat was like oh my God you're awful and
then the guy just happened to come back
he was like oh my God you've broken the
presents
really just really weird situation yeah
you live London on Queens
[Music]
how has your like Excel London event
where the guy came up on stage that
looked fun that's one of the harder ones
that was uh that was a learning
experience yeah
um I mean you never know how you're
going to act in that kind of situation
until that kind of happens I guess and I
guess we learn a lot about trash taste
and we learned a lot about ourselves as
well that was just the deer in the
headlights the entirely yeah like
completely out of it he was kind of
quiet and you were like you know you've
got your favorite school teacher you
don't want to disappoint and then they
lecture you that's right it was like
okay mate you've got your fun games
you're like your favorite teachers just
like told you off okay because because
like I was prepared to throw hands but I
wanted to like de-escalate the situation
before so I think I just wanted to like
disappointed parents mode right because
like before you throw hands you like to
me when I hear like the disappointed
voice that hits me harder than if
someone's like screaming shouting at me
because like oh [ __ ] I've done something
wrong guys I'm sorry sir it did not mean
anything no words did not mean anything
to that guy yeah but also we should have
never been in a situation where we even
had to consider throwing hands yeah but
we spoke about that and the security was
terrible until it wasn't yeah they
sorted that out real quick we wasn't
exactly The Bodyguard no one threw
themselves
from SAS yeah yeah I love there's a clip
of you at the one in Los Angeles what
was the event called Anime Expo yeah
yeah and you're like walking with like a
[ __ ] Army of men like
it's like I used to be able to relate to
Sea Dog yeah
private Jeff Bezos
[ __ ] 300 when you walked into that
event in the videos
what happened someone down a hole Yeah I
mean we didn't we we wanted security for
that we didn't say hey we want 10. but I
think they just kept sporty they were
like I think what happened was someone
was like we need more people because
yeah this is too much we need more I I
think yeah I think MCM set a standard
and everyone saw that or all the
conventions all that because all the
conventions that we went to referred to
that like incident to be like we don't
want to repeat of that how come you
don't do conventions
I I'm doing an event in London when I go
back like Anime conventions or something
I'm sure you get invited I don't know
anymore
I only got invite I did get invited to
one of this year Japan was uh Japan Expo
where the Japan expert there's the the
UK one as well I can't remember what
that's called I think if I'd been
invited to the one you guys went to I'd
have been like yeah I'll go really yeah
MCM yeah yeah I've been invited to one
called an amazement in North Korea oh
yeah yeah which is like a that's like an
anime slash like Japan yeah I got
invited one in hyper Japan that's the
one in the UK Japan hyper Japan I'd do
that if they invited me yeah I haven't
invited me before but I know the price
is right of course if the camembert's
there
they just leave trails
[Applause]
if it's a Japan one then probably I
could do it but anime what can I talk
about again you don't I love Akira yeah
you don't talk you just sit there and
sign autographs where's the fun in that
me you get to meet your fans I do want
to meet my my family I got this um
because I haven't been back to the UK at
Christmas Chris is my favorite time of
year I've got this event in London that
I'm doing and it's gonna say like 500
people there and I'll you know meet them
there that'll be fun have you ever done
like a public event where you get to
like meet your like viewers and fans and
everything like that yeah well you did
that first journey across Japan I did
one after generic across Japan and I
feel like I did another one that I've
forgotten us I guess the short answer
yeah I did I did some stuff for TC but
like no I I'm all for it I've got a
Halloween event as well excited YouTube
but you're going to be in Wisconsin so
yeah or somewhere in the far flung now
we'll be in Portland yeah yeah so I've
got like a Halloween event meet up thing
that's coming up so I've got like two
events yeah in Japan nice so I'm doing
some stuff but no like yeah I'd I'd be
up for doing a convention yeah
opportunities there The Price is Right
have you ever signed anything before or
fans and everything like that yeah it's
usually the photos though isn't it yeah
yeah I had a guy in Don Quixote like the
mega donkey Hotel Shibu wants to come up
to me and he wanted a signature and I
was filming a TC video doing something
and I was like if you've got a pen it
was like no I was like how's this going
to work then so we've spent five to ten
minutes walking around Don Quijote
amidst the shoot I was doing trying to
find a pin so I could sign something for
this guy yeah he was a little bit rude
like most people are nice this guy
wasn't and uh I was not watching but we
found a pen I was like okay we've got
the pen let's let's get this sign what
do you want to sign he's like actually
can't just take a photo
that's why I don't do signings
yeah we literally one of this like
Indiana Jones fetch quest to get a
[ __ ] pet for nothing yeah you
searched for it yeah why did you say I
did it was being nice I was like I'll
find this pen we'll get the Superman you
should just be like oh you got a pair
and then I don't know why after this
like Adventure he flipped and was ah you
know let's just have a photo yeah he did
and he had his 10 minutes of fun so that
was all tactical see because like yeah
he just wanted to spend time with you be
like yes I don't have them yeah but yeah
I mean I did this when I did this TC
event after journey across Japan one we
had about 100 people there and I I spent
an hour I think I spoke to every single
person yeah and I I enjoy it yeah
meeting people so did you use uh did you
have to make up a signature on the spot
yeah do you have a signature my
signature in it do I have a signature no
like Chopsticks do you have enough yeah
do you have an Abron Japan signature
yeah Japan signature
it's just like a variation of
um my real signature oh I've seen it
because 10 000 people have tagged me
every time someone gets an aparri shirt
and you've got more dripping
literally I don't know how many shirts
you've sold it must be a billion because
every [ __ ] day for the last three
months it's like you've got more driven
Krishna because every time you get a
share that is the thing it says I don't
know who signed off on this I'm gonna
have one of you killed
taken for granted because we because
three of us three of us are three
different messages and it gets
randomized next time we'll provide three
different messages to Chris when we uh
every shirt you sell I get tagged again
Chris no no so I've seen your signature
a few times are you not worried about
having your real signature helper uh is
that something you need to worry about
or I mean signature or anything like
people we're gonna start cashing checks
if someone if they happen to like grab
your bank information they could easily
sign off on it if they know what your
signature
I've not done a convention there's a
thousand people my signature exactly I
remember ax
um uh we were doing signings together
and then this was the first year
obviously we had like trash taste at a
convention and then someone saw mail in
the background and they asked for her
signature and malin's like never signed
anything in her life and so we call her
over she excitedly you know excited to
get her to sign her first thing and then
as she starts she puts the pen down and
I go mail in do not put your real
signature down yeah yeah this is this is
make up a fake signature and then she
puts the pen down and I'm like I said
that I didn't I like crashed her for
like five minutes I think she was like
and your security
down there's three magic numbers
Jesus I remember Pete Premiere too did a
twitch stream once and showed off my
business card with my phone number and I
was like you [ __ ] God I'm gonna have
you kill but he like took down the
stream
I was like Jesus
yeah you should probably make up a new
signature what would it be
yeah come on how did you make a camera
Barry Chopsticks
and BC my initials reversed
broad Christmas
all right I'll remember that yeah no I
would say yes to a convention if the if
the opportunity right and the pressure's
right and the prices yeah okay in
America or UK or anywhere yeah I'd like
to do it so I actually turned one down
in Italy oh just because I just come out
from the UK and I didn't want to go all
the way to Europe what kind of
convention was it like uh Japan it was a
Japan anime convention I can't remember
the entire name of it and um I thought I
thought about it yeah Freehold it Italy
it was but then I was like but then I
have to probably go to the UK and see my
family and friends